salve questa è un'occasione per dare
voce ad alcune esperienze
che ho fatto nella mia vita esperienze
così diverse che potrei anche parlare di
vite diverse
sono qui a raccontarvi alcuni sogni che
ho realizzato e che
da idee sono diventati fatti fatti
concreti
questa mia prima vita che
è durata 22 anni il sistema bancario
mi ha vista protagonista in
diversi casi di successo e ho lavorato
nel campo nel settore della finanza
tesoreria commerciale marketing nei
settori tradizionali della banca e poi
mi è stato dato un piccolo compito e
così ho creato il primo modello di banca
multicanale virtuale in italia e
grande successo questa capacità di
creare dei modelli e degli strumenti di
lavoro utili agli impiegati ai clienti
mi ha dato la possibilità di guardarmi
intorno e ho pensato di cambiare
esperienza rimanendo sempre nel mondo
della finanza e quindi dal primo modello
di banca virtuale ho scelto di
vivere quattro anni a milano in
un'esperienza simile nel mondo della
finanza ma in un'azienda molto più ampia
più grande e ho creato dei modelli anche
lì di automazione dei processi di
conoscenza e san paolo imi ho creato una
piattaforma di knowledge management dove
in tempo reale tutte le informazioni
arrivavano dalla fabbrica di prodotto
fondi gestioni patrimoniali alle reti
delle filiali grande successo grande
iniziativa abbastanza interessanti mi
hanno chiesto perché guadagnavo
veramente tanti soldi mi hanno chiesto
di proseguire la famosa carriera e
girare il mondo per
razionalizzare le filiali estere della
rete sanpaolo imi e quindi dovevo andare
in giro per i paesi dell'est asia e
rivedere un po tutto il sistema di
offerta delle reti delle filiali
qui è scattata una molla e ho cominciato
a provare del disagio nel in questa mia
fine della prima vita e ho
provato disagio perché oggi è più
sotto gli occhi di tutti
l'inadeguatezza del sistema bancario in
italia e nel mondo
evidente e abbiamo visto anche i
fallimenti delle imprese ma soprattutto
dovuti non è l'incapacità o la mancanza
di creatività degli imprenditori spesso
perché le banche
lasciano sempre il cerino corto al
cliente mi sono sentita
un po fuori luogo
e qui diciamo mi sono persa allora ho
cominciato a pensare di poter dare
quella mia energia quella voglia quella
tenace a quella voglia di cambiamento di
metterla in gioco e di proporla in altri
modelli allora
sono andata ho fatto una breve
esperienza in brasile dove volevo avere
un contatto diretto con la povertà ero
molto ricca una ricchezza fatta di soldi
volevo cercare una ricchezza diversa una
ricchezza interiore e così ho messo un
nuovo paio di occhiali e ho visto la
vita in modo differente così ho messo in
piedi la mia impresa sociale e quindi
nella seconda vita ho fondato officina
creativa lanciando vari progetti che
toccavano vari temi settori dimenticati
ho lavorato con i minori a rischio di
devianza
ho lavorato
nel campo della comunicazione sociale
nelle scuole parlando di energia
rinnovabile e di risparmio energetico
ho
sviluppato modelli che potessero
dare valore a dei comportamenti
intangibili che sono quello quelli del
pagamento delle la puntualità nel
pagamento delle bollette dell'acqua ad
esempio e ho messo in piedi tante
attività lanciando dei brand e dei
modelli dei nuovi modelli di sviluppo è
nato poi il grande amore con made in
carcere perché
il mio desiderio era quello di incidere
in situazioni estremamente disagiate
made in carcere è un'esperienza molto
interessante ed è questa la mia seconda
vita e già ho in mente
nel 2013 credo che partirà senz'altro
che ci riuscirò e un'esperienza di una
summer school
perché il mio sogno da realizzare nella
mia vecchiaia è quello di stare sempre
insieme ai bambini quindi creare una
casa famiglia delle summer school creare
dei modelli tra virgolette educativi e
formativi
pieni di gioia ed ironia tornando alla
seconda vita e il progetto che sta
prendendo più tempo e che occupa gran
parte della mia vita
e questo contatto che ho con il mondo
del carcere
contatto molto
difficile molto forte come impatto però
vero dove l'assenza di qualsiasi
elemento genera
il massimo della creatività e sviluppa
un
un senso della creatività ma anche della
sopravvivenza molto forte ho cominciato
questo progetto di made in carcere
pensando
nel momento in cui ho visto tante buste
di carta che si distruggevano nel giro
di poche ore due ore due giorni al
massimo con le borse tutte patinate
bellissime ho pensato che potesse essere
utile far cucire perché è molto semplice
cucinare una busta e abbiamo pensato di
realizzare del package per la spesa per
fare dei regali ma anche per seminari ed
eventi è semplicemente invece portarmi
le borse portone etichetta stampare
l'etichetta dello sponsor attaccarla
sulla busta di tessuto e questa busta
che ha il marchio quindi che gira quindi
va avanti il concetto di diffusione
della conoscenza attraverso questa
formula di marketing sociale riesce a
durare tanto tempo anche anni e quindi
il messaggio continua ad essere
veicolato ma il progetto emoziona e
quindi
raccoglie una sensibilità
data appunto dall'attenzione dell'uso
delle cose che noi già abbiamo
perché spesso
noi usiamo infatti i prodotti riciclati
tessuti rimanenze di magazzino o
scarti e spesso vengono abbandonati nei
depositi noi invece li
raccogliamo qui a como ci sono anche
delle associazioni no profit che ci
donano tantissimi tessuti l'associazione
mare di moda la cosa interessante è che
tutti sono felici
chiaramente
noi esistiamo perché
le donne detenute percepiscono regolare
stipendio poi vedremo un po più a fondo
questo pensiero e
noi esistiamo se qualcuno ci conosce e
allora invece di fare delle borse
fashion molto belle epoque e e costose
ho scelto di fare molte borse a
pochissimo prezzo che possono andare dai
2 ai 5 euro in modo tale da diffondere e
contaminare quanto più è possibile un
modello di sviluppo che tocca un nuovo
stile di vita un nuovo modo di stare sul
mercato ma anche di usare le cose che
noi abbiamo quindi
stile di vita filosofia che ci ha
consentito di assumere oltre 22 detenute
abbiamo anche altre risorse esterne che
lavorano per aiutarci appunto nella
comunicazione e nel marketing
e
con due euro 5 euro alla volta siamo
riusciti adesso per esempio a metà
ottobre abbiamo fino a metà ottobre
abbiamo fatturato oltre 400 mila euro e
questo significa che posso restituire
una gioia di una ricchezza che non che
non è fatta più di soldi di denaro ma è
fatta di esperienza e di contatto con
con questi esseri umani queste
situazioni estremamente disagi disagiate
e solitamente inaccessibili
la mia esperienza nel campo
dell'innovazione tecnologica e
nell'innovazione sociale mi hanno
consentito proprio di lavorare su
un'offerta estremamente interessante e
ho pensato quindi che la conoscenza
sull'innovazione applicata al buon senso
che dato appunto da questo circolo
virtuoso dove tutti sono contenti dove
tutti vincono perché chi dona il tessuto
si libera dai magazzini dei tessuti
bellissimi che spesso
procurano sofferenze procura sofferenza
il donagli buttarvi nella spazzatura
però se vengono donati e vengono
riutilizzati sicuramente
anche gli imprenditori un compiono
un'azione
sociale noi con un camper andiamo a
raccogliere l'italiano li facciamo
cucire all'interno delle carceri facendo
tantissime borse di tutti i tipi adesso
abbiamo fatto anche delle borsette per
uso tecnologico per il porta ipad
abbiamo fatto il pigiamino per questi
prodotti di tecnologia quindi oltre alle
buste della spesa le borse per gli
eventi ad esso i package per prodotti
tecnologici quindi l'innovazione
applicata al buon senso per noi è un
modello di buon uso nel mondo e vorrei
farvi vedere e toccare con mano
quello di cui vi appare
made in carcere
praticamente la mia seconda vita
questa volta che non fanno come vogliono
loro
la detenuta percepisce un regolare
stipendio e quindi lo stipendio
significa ferie straordinari malattia
certificato medico assegni familiari
ritardo orari
l'ingresso e l'uscita la pausa caffè
sono tutte i concetti che nel nel
reinserimento del lavoro nel mondo reale
sono percepiti ma spesso una detenuta
non ha neanche mai lavorato e quindi
sono concetti forti importanti che
aiutano
proprio un meccanismo di reinserimento
nel mondo reale a bruxelles a settimana
europea per le piccole e medie imprese
in aperture vincitori del concorso per i
migliori video 2010 la corrispondente
mariolina sattanino la crisi ci ha
insegnato a guardare il mondo con occhi
diversi ha detto il vicepresidente della
commissione tajani dialogando con
imprenditori svedesi romeni croati e con
due imprenditrici italiane luciana delle
donne che ha creato una cooperativa per
aiutare le detenute producendo con
tessuti riciclati lecce carcere di
massima sicurezza reparto femminile
qui nasce il marchio made in carcere di
reato da luciana delle donne insieme un
gruppo di detenute
mi ha portato alle stoffe tre anni quali
ci hanno lasciato la carriera di
bancaria milano è tornata in puglia e ha
avviato una cooperativa sociale qui si
lavora al recupero della dignità delle
persone e insieme si recuperano anche
materiali di scarto tessuti che gli
stilisti avrebbero buttato via vengono
riciclati in oggetti di moda dietro al
marchio made in carcere ci sono di tre
laboratori sartoriali tra le carceri di
lecce e trani per un totale di 22
detenute è stato inviate come il
ricavato delle vendite della loro
impresa che riduce soprattutto borse per
convegni e confessore simpanen amara che
un posto così brutto e all'ammenda non
bello non puoi non essere entrato nella
musica di tutto perché
poi diventa tutto sembra che è trovato
il paradiso è ovvio
e senz'altro all'esperienza forte che
crea un impatto che quello che forse
oggi
serve a tutti quanti così degli appunti
questa questo suicidio dell'economia
questo accompagnamento
alla povertà di valori
quindi voglio dire il cambiamento quello
che noi stiamo vivendo il caos quello è
un mio
schizzo che spiega il mio progetto dove
c'è sempre caos dove c'è sempre
ripensamento ma dove c'è una visione
estremamente
lucida nel senso che non è possibile
non
fermarsi non generare un cambiamento che
abbia in considerazione il benessere e
sociale diffuso non è possibile
continuare
ad arricchirsi alle spalle degli altri
ad avere atteggiamenti di omertà e a non
ribellarsi in situazioni di estremo
disagio e diciamo che ci comporta
parecchio personalmente mi comporta
parecchio disagio e questo è un modo per
esprimere che si può fare invece con dei
modelli di sviluppo sostenibili si può
fare impresa e quindi il mio progetto
può essere replicato a livello
industriale può avere un salto
dimensionale e su 67 mila detenuti il 10
per cento e femminile invece di 22
vorrei averne 2.200 di detenute che
cucinano il package perché la busta
serve a sempre a tutti e abbiamo avuto
un'esperienza abbastanza interessante e
7 mosse per l'italia con una barca a
vela ci siamo allontanati dall'italia
per pensare e cercare di individuare dei
modelli di innovazione sociale dove
potesse esserci una visione diversa del
mondo e dare un contributo
abbiamo scritto un libro io ho scritto
alcune cose
che poi comunque potete trovare
scaricabile sul sul web è la cosa che
più è importante lasciare un segno nel
cambiamento il mio indirizzo e mail e
luciana 7 24 7 giorni su 7 24 ore su 24
chiocciola
gmail.it
naturalmente
ciò solo minuto naturalmente
non posso non farvi vedere alcuni dei
nostri prodotti e quindi vi saluto
offrendovi un piccolo catalogo dei
nostri prodotti ok